So finally, the Omaha is also known as UKVI
as already stipulated and put forward the date
to stop care workers
from bringing their dependents into the United Kingdom.
Last year, this was proposed
and this was
the motion was moved and a lot of things were said,
but there was no actual date.
But the Home Secretary has come out today
and he has announced the date.
So from 11th of March 2024.
So that's in about two weeks time.
They are saying they want to cut
the rate of migration into the country.
So, um, not only that,
the minimum amount that you can hand
to get a sponsorship for a skilled work officer
has been raised to £26,200 annually.
So that means
employers need to offer more
to be able to give a sponsorship visa.
Don't forget
care worker visa is different from skilled worker visa.
So there are a lot of things on the page.
There are so many things and, um,
I liked it on,
on that page on,
on that page
on golf dot UK,
you can check it by yourself and read everything.
So I know a lot of questions will be running through
people's mind.
Anything you've not seen on the UK
on the government UK is speculation.
So I would suggest that, um,
everybody calms down. Um,
unfortunately,
what can we do at this point in time?
I know it's not a good news at all,
but for them,
for the Home
Office is a good news,
but for immigrants is not a good news,
is not a palatable news at all.
But what can we do?
There is migration issues all over the world.
Even in one of our dream countries
in an aspiring president
is planning the largest deportation
in the history of the United States of America.
So there is migration issues everywhere in the world.
So mmm is the best bet is look before you leap.
We started the year with no grief for anybody.
But then one month into the New Year,
they are not grieving for us.
It is well, but still
no grief for anybody.
And look before you leap
so that you don't leap into trouble. Peace out.